c'est le dernier voyage du commandant
robert piché
[Musique]
il prend sa retraite d'air transat
il ne sera plus en uniforme lorsque les
gens vont lui demander sa photo parce
qu'ils se font ils iront à le faire
quand ils recollaient c'était en 2001
mais personne n'a oublié pour moi c'est
un héros il a sauvé la vie de centaines
de personnes
il était brave et puis je pense que sans
lui les gens les gens seraient morts
vol 236 toronto lisbonne il y à une
fuite
l'avion perd tout son carburant les
moteurs s'arrêtent
cette finale c'était le temps n'a rosa
ça c'était pas évident d'y rejouer bras
je dois quand même à 100 milles
nautiques 160 km des moteurs
fonctionnent pas comment cet avion le
voyage et puis toi en tant qu'être
humain tu vas mourir dans dix minutes la
fermeture et déjà sa première marque à
ta mort imminente d'un président qui
travaille comme il faut autre chose
quelque chose survient habituellement de
l'avion il plane ça c'est vous le
savions mais ça m'a surpris de l'avion
place se comportait très bien
le commandant robert piché a réussi à
poser danger on sonne sans carburant ni
moteur 160 km en vol plané
le supplice des 293 passagers et 13
membres d'équipage va durer vingt
minutes
une éternité d'angoise mortels ce que le
commandant piché a décidé de faire de
figure pas dans les manuels de pilotage
je pense qu'un reporter à une perte de
carburant machine qui amène dans
l'extinction des deux moteurs après
mille l'océan atlantique de nuit je
pense pourtant urgence moi je pense que
tu tomberas survie c'est une coche plus
hautes qu'elles urgence
là c'est une question de procédure une
question étant survie faute face que tu
as à faire pour rester en vie
la survie tamanu certain nadal n à
l'être humain qui permet de faire des
choses qu'en temps normal y'a un peu
diable de faire des progrès il aurait pu
s'en passer
et puis il sait que bientôt la presse va
révéler qu'il était condamné à 10 ans de
prison aux etats-unis pour trafic de
drogue et qu'il a passé 16 mois derrière
les barreaux trade à présent quand même
quelques points affecté fier de déchets
c'est ça qui est ça qu elle monte par
les austères que je fais de mon
atterrissage devenue héroïne semaine
après 0,1 fake c'est beaucoup d'émotion
pour un être hommage et en très peu de
temps
dans une semaine non j'ai utilisé mon
jour là j'allais pour moi aussi
j'aimerais que de mourir
cet instinct de survie robert piché nous
a confié qu'il l'avait acquis en prison
justement je certain que cette
expérience m'a aidée soir-là commandant
piché sont les remis mais ce n'a pas été
facile
les québécois sont mahler de moi si
j'avais eu les québécois dallas la
réaction répète contraire on veut
pouvoir avec lui en tant que personne
ça m'a au moins deux ans redevenir
l'homme que j'ai tel que c'est un homme
brésilien
je suis vraiment honoré de savoir que ce
soir il était avec nous à bord de
l'avion
le commandant piché se prête toujours de
bonne grâce aux demandes du public
sa popularité l'aide pour sa fondation
qui finance des organismes qui oeuvrent
auprès des personnes qui ont développé
une dépendance à l'alcool à la drogue et
au jeu pathologique est que va-t-il
faire de sa retraite
voyager mon rêve quand j'étais agent
c'est à dire faire le tour du monde
ce que je comprends n'a pas su passer
vos somme n'est qu'un comptage il
fallait donner une soupe au lait chinois
lavin genre de petit présentoir à
l'école il fallait mettre un sou pour
donner au chien ça m'intriguait j'avais
7 8 mg pourquoi freud lundi s'ouvre le
chinois qui restent à l'autre bout du
monde un jour j'aimerais avoir à les
voir pourquoi la passion du voyage m est
venue ce soir il part pour rome
c'est un souhait de sa femme pour son
anniversaire marie il faut pas seulement
lui a permis de choisir son dernier vol
et son copilote cette banane ici ce
qu'on veut peut-être ce n'est en contact
de temps à temps
et oui parce que je voyais beaucoup la
vie depuis l' international gros
portables mac
les pilotes du monde entier considèrent
que le commandant piché a réalisé un des
plus grands exploits de l'histoire de
l'aviation
le 24 août 2001 il est entré à jamais
dans la légende d'attraction de la
destination de londres c'est votre
[Musique]